was machst du denn da sag mal was ist
denn los
ich hab das likes bekommen elf schon
aber das ist doch gar nicht so schlimm
die hassen mich und die finden mich auch
nicht witzig ja das kann doch nicht
jeder deine videos gut finden
und warum nicht du magst doch am
liebsten schokoladeneis ruder oder und
mag ich am liebsten schokoladen 130
nicht du bist nur von mir erfunden
vanessa nein deine lieblings ortes
erdbeere siehst du aber vielleicht
könnte ich ja nackt durch feuerringe
springen nein das kannst du mitmachen
let's place jeder marketplace christ
viel zu schnell ich kaufen uns eine
katze und ziehen der einen keine katzen
in lustigen kostümen die leute lieben
katzen wie die einsätze
du machst jetzt einfach mit dem weiter
was du jetzt tust und es wird immer
leute geben die das nicht mögen
verstanden was machst du denn da jetzt
sieht das bescheuert 8000